this year a lot of the ads were sad  sentimental one of them I think you know  which one I'm talking about was  downright depressing I'm talking about  the Nationwide Insurance ad that  featured a cute little boy and it had a  horrifying ending take a look I never  learned to fly or travel the world with  my best friend  and they won't ever get married I  couldn't go off because I died from an  accident yes that was a real ad that is  so depressing everybody today is talking  about it but I'm realizing there was  another commercial that didn't get  nearly as much attention but I thought  was equally sad I don't take a look at  this one  [Music]  resume death  go-gurt enjoy it while you still can  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  it actually makes me want to get some co  Girt right away what I'm having for  dinner but there's still time I want  go-gurt  you